Hey hello Jenna's making me do something
right now and I'm not too happy about it
neither see hey I'm super excited about
it
so we were talking about in my book
there was this kids to you who kicked me
is crazy I finally need to really kick
Justin it's not nice but you definitely
did do it this would be great book
number two he kicks you again twenty
spell do I don't know it doesn't matter
the kick happened in sixth grade and
what year was sixth grade Steve do we
remember uh what do you do you have like
five to the grade and that gets your age
or something huh yeah
wait no we're looking for the year wait
when did the arleigh be peace what did
their first album around Oh 99 the
matchbox 20 album do you remember the me
- okay so clumsy came out in 1996 so
yeah that would make Arabs I mention be
seven so yeah 96 97 that was because I
remember I got my first CDs in sixth
grade I do tell me
it was it was combo Britney Spears the
original I get to know Britni album and
then also no strings attached Oh was the
same year but those words like the first
ones I bought I think no doubt matchbox
wanting in our lives
how's it going it's so good to see Steve
what opposed to kick each other okay
come on get back over here knows are you
disputing we're gonna trade kick I'm
pretty sure I was wasted for it so gonna
try it's true it's true you guys not
agree Mike like on see you basically
played a huge part in the creation from
from what I heard in our audio book
which I loved your audiobook if you've
read the book like it's great to read
the book but it's really awesome to hear
the audio version rancor is coming for
dinner afterward that's cool we sat by
some Tigers he said with great I had a
great time but I'm going to see you in
Texas that's why we couldn't really
remember because they just saw you so I
was like wait I'm vlogging I remember
you vlog for me and I remember editing
you were vlogging which was how do you
feel about having a dog named after you
see I don't feel privileged at all cuz I
don't get to do anything with a dog you
need to play I don't get to play with a
dog cuz the way I want to play the dogs
I wanted to jump off the couch no and
you won't let me jump off the couch
no he's fine like 11 years old in dog
years
I realize that I'm an adult
we were youtubing today that's what this
is not let's all try gluten-free
pretzels gluten-free for real I'm gluten
free but not by choice everyone acts
like oh why did you do that at mine
because I have to yeah I wouldn't give
up cave Pizza reply there's a gif can
just mine that's pretty hard got that
for you that's it it's a terrarium oh
that's hurtful that's how you live out
your bed wouldn't you think my
collections complete
I'm gonna think I'm the girl the girl
you want thingamabobs like I'm sweating
but okay do you actually Matty's every
kitchen drawers will be sleeping
this is creepy beyond creepy just a lamb
chop yeah that's his favorite toy out of
everything he doesn't even care sure
actually but he liked this this one is
super creepy video left each other yet
they're gonna have to get a picture with
Maddie and put them in the Maddie book I
have this looks like you in like high
school almost like why does it look so
get out right now we should be on the
mat Lila Spotify look could we invite
you to it no okay
I'm
was
Friday night around
that's any indication of fun we clearly
had fun last night we did actually have
a lot of fun right now we're off to
puppy kindergarten and BAE and dad
number one is here just me just got this
new bag so if their roles like a
suitcase does little man loves it it's
great we're gonna be a look at him oh my
god I'm in love with you Maddie I'm in
love with you oh uh what do you mean
okay
we're out to puppy school late because
I've always look at Maddie in the back
seat look at him he's precious little
cargo back there
no no look at him he's just chewing on
his little toys
Maddie look here good boy he's like I
got this one ready yes good boy what do
you think of your son is so talented
he's so talented orrible I don't know
there's a cuties in here
good boy yes I'm sorry she does your
treat yeah oh you're so good say hi
we picked up what is even happening
right now
it's really hot in here
black leather is nothing but we've got
the air on and Mattie's enjoying his
little snoop razor this snoozer if you
guys want to gonna let me drive drove
flying vlogs no I just love to say hey I
picked you guys up I'm gonna get
cupcakes we are I didn't even end this
vlog oh well I'm ending it now hope you
guys are doing well and Maddie is taking
a little nap over there uh I just love
him see you guys in the next video peace
out I was gonna say something else but I
I blocked out today is a very exciting
day today we are going wedding-dress
shopping